okay so the first of the four steps is
Darla take all the data you got in the
question okay and take it into account
I'll show you what that means
secondly you're going to need to form
the parametric equations okay you're
gonna have to get an x equals something
right in terms of the peas and the Q's
and you'll have a y equals something in
terms of peas in compute okay
now based on that you might be able to
guess what the third step is if two is
parametric then three years
Cartesian questions so you want to take
those two parametric ones and you want
to combine them together and eliminate
the parameter Z so doing okay and the
last step is restrictions okay so let's
do it to go through one by one now Donna
let's have a look at this thing one two
these two lines are really actually
giving you a lot of clues right but it's
a matter of us seeing where those crews
are and in you know actually putting
them into a form that's useful for the
question okay so let's start with nice
easy ones okay out of this x squared
equals 8y you can already know a piece
of data right namely the focal length
what is it - so from there I get a
equals two now called PQ passes through
this point so that's that's his a lot
already okay now P and Q they're kind of
just imply what those points are right
so from here I would say well point P
right it's got to have some kind of
coordinates and I need to work with this
so what are they generally we'd say to
AP AP squared well we can do better than
that because we know what a is right so
instead I'm gonna have for P to P spit
so far so good
okay now likewise I'm gonna have Q
Q's instead of peas okay
so again all I'm doing here is just
taking into account the data that's up
here haven't done any actual problem
solver okay all right now if the cord
passes through this point how am I going
to take this into account what should I
do if I ever caught if a line goes
through a certain point what that
geometric property algebraically what it
means it is the equation of this line
should be satisfied by this x value this
Y values does that make sense okay so
I'm gonna have to sub in to 0 into
equation for the court does that make
sense
ok now I've sort of been playing a
little bit faster news and I have just
been say ah here's the equation of the
chord you have learnt it ok but let's do
this the full proper way let's derive
the equation of the court given that
these are our two points
ok so how do I do it just yeah I I could
do gradient and then go ahead from there
but I might as well do two point four
because that's got the grading
calculation sort of embedded within it
okay so in case you can't remember let's
have this just so you point formula
okay so let's go ahead and go through it
now the way that I do it is I think
about okay just cool one of the points
one the other point - it doesn't matter
which ones which but because this x1 y1
this x1 y1 they just re up here right
I'm gonna write all of those bits first
off of this so I don't get my bits and
pieces confused
okay so if this is X 1 and this is y 1
okay right away I'm gonna write minus CP
squared minus 2p squared it's the same
on both sides right and on the
denominators - full pay
is that okay so those bits are the same
now put in the different bits Y and X
and these bits will be the same but just
with huge ok anyway okay so now you've
got a you've just got a machine this out
okay
having gotten to here simplify it out
you're at a bit of an advantage because
you know what to expect at the end okay
so do the algebra just for the sake of
I'm not gonna write it all down but what
you should end up is let's see okay oh
you could have the to TQ of the other
side that doesn't matter okay so don't
forget you do need these lines in here
and you'll see when you get a question
like this this will be worth like three
or four where there's three or four
marks go part of it will be in this
proof okay so don't just jump there
you've got to have two point four okay
now what was the point of me doing that
again why did I bother deriving this
equation yeah good I'm still in step one
right
I wanted to sub in this guy so let's go
ahead and do that okay if you want to
put some words under it and say the cord
passes through
- not okay so now I can do my
substitution and don't just come from
their way okay okay
behalf of the two in the middle there
they cancel I can bring that to PQ over
the other side so here's what I've got
all right now are you happy with that
now this point I have accounted for all
of the data in the question okay it's a
bit of a confusing step because there's
no it's not as obvious what you do next
it's not like okay now I differentiate
it now I'll do this and so on
this step is finished so now I'm going
to go on to my next one okay the
parametric equations this will come in
handy later so handy that I'm going to
call this equation one okay so that I
can refer to it afterwards all right how
do I go about forming these parametric
equations well I'm gonna need to define
my locus somehow right this midpoint
okay so usually with lockers questions
but for parametric's how we start a
lockers question what's the very first
thing you say lab now we used to say P
right but peas taken and we've already
got one calling him so let em right be
at and put in some corners these are the
parametric equations that I'm gonna fall
okay
now seeing as it's a midpoint we know
how to find midpoints right how will I
get the x coordinate of the midpoint
okay so I'll take the average yeah yeah
wait sorry which step are you
questioning just good do you have X
equal station and Wieck was that oh yeah
okay yeah that's fine
I still prefer to do it this way because
I'm getting equations that go into an
equation so that may come into my head
but yeah we're gonna have the same
amount of information on the page this
phone okay I know what they say we're
gonna take the average right so half off
for P or Q right so there's my
parametric equation for x we'll do the
same for y which is equal to mmm I'll
skip a step there we go okay you're
happy with that okay so this is it
let me get another color I didn't bring
myself those there's other parametric
equations okay so now how do I put it
together I am I am gonna have to do use
this in a second okay
when I look at these how am I gonna put
them together it seems like it would be
easier to go from this one to this one
because from here to here I take the
square okay whereas universe it's kind
of weird okay so let's go with this X
equation right I'm gonna divide it all
by 2 which gives me this right so now to
get this toward the Y equation I've got
to square so square both sides
so far so good and that's why you can
see why we went through all this Ehlert
effort at the beginning accounting for
the data so we could get this equation
which would be super useful in a minute
okay
this guy here what's that that's why
okay
this part here two P Q is P plus Q plus
Q right all right we already know what P
plus Q is right we work that out just up
here okay so I've got X on two or
squared equals that now I can finally
get rid of all of my friends okay
so some sensors this is step three and
step three is sort of done I just have
to tidy this up a little bit okay now
once you do that once did you tie it up
you'll get it into one of two forms okay
so this is just simplify it's sort of I
don't know three or four lines in there
um you can get it in the form y equals
and you'll have this okay what other
form could we possibly put it in yeah
okay I might want a general form right
and we express all of these in the same
way so alternatively you'd have this and
of course you've got a complete square
to get to this point okay but does that
match up with what people have gone yes
okay so I'm happy with that data dump
average equations does Cartesian
equation done how shall I find their
restrictions which way do you think
would be best the graph or the
discriminant how did you go that funny
in who used the graph yeah okay so does
that mean who use the discriminant is
that okay yeah okay sure all right
Daniel's like I just clicked my fingers
I think the graph is a probably a better
way to do it it's a bit quicker
is the specific here let's draw a quick
graph of x squared equals a y and we'll
put it next to this one okay so we can
compare the two and then we can make a
geometric argument you have to draw a
graph that's good enough to argue from
right so if for instance hmm well I mean
it does have to have the critical points
that I'm going to talk about the domain
that I'm going to argue that that has to
be good enough on there that I can look
at the graph and say oh yeah that's 0
that's for like it's not like negative 2
or something like that ok but no it
doesn't have to be beautiful because the
question does not say graph we are just
happening to use graphing as the most
convenient tool to finding it right so
here's what you want to end up with
roughly mm-hmm x-ray equals a why that's
kind of a fat looking thing right when
you see that coefficient on the Y the
bigger that is the wider the focal
length okay so that's that's why I'm
taller so why now when you have a look
at this let's think about you can use
either form okay you can read off
different things from each form okay so
for instance from this form you can read
off the roots the roots 0 and sorry
and from this one you can read off
something quite different right what do
you get from this the vertex right so
what do you know about the vertex where
is it good which which is that kind of
fear that kind of makes sense with this
because the vertex is halfway between
the roots okay
so let's draw it in fact what they're
about okay now if you have made a graph
it is crucially important that you label
it okay because you need to distinguish
between the original graph and the
Bacchus that you're gonna have so this
white one that's my next grade why and
I've got this one in the middle okay so
now I have to say and you must say this
mm-hmm from the ground okay volakis that
we're interested in which is a midpoint
right must lie and I think we were
talked about this before but I say
inside or within both of those words are
fine they are unambiguous in this case
right so the waters have a midpoint PQ
must lie within xp8 what right so what
you've got to go ahead and do is find
well where is that section that works
and it's this section this pile is
inside this is not okay shouldn't I dent
off' i the right domain on this point of
intersection that's convenient and this
point okay so i think you can probably
you guys are in year 11 so you can work
out you can solve simultaneously you
should get zero and four okay and so
your restriction is
X is less than or equal to zero or the
other side okay any questions yeah so in
this case right the cord right now I
apologize I didn't do a bit of homework
on this one because it's kind of a a
question as to whether you can have a
cord which has no length right so if P
and Q are on the same sides are
basically now I've seen some questions
that say P and Q can't be equal so right
in the beginning of a question you'll
say you know they said so they must be
distinct points in which case how would
that change our answer yeah it just
means I don't I don't include the
boundary point that's the difference
okay but I promise I'll go do my
homework and I'll double-check if not to
apply in all cases in which case your
inequality would be just that ever so
slightly different okay but just to
review take into account the data
probably allow you to get up at this
point right for your parametric
equations stick them together and get
your cartesian one and then either
graphically write or algebraically using
the discriminant go ahead and work out
what the streets yourself that's